hello everyone so welcome to another
episode of unlocking lily it's always
been my dream to be a speaker which led
me to quit my day job to work in mentor
under Evan full time and all of you are
coming along for the ride with me in
every episode I take on a different
challenge you really help me grow as a
speaker in this video I'm gonna be
starting with my oh why because I
learned from simon Sinek it's important
for you to know your why before you know
your how and what everyone so today is a
day I'm gonna be teaching a one word
workshop at the library I'm gonna do
something a little bit different than
usual instead of telling people what I
do I'm gonna start with my why I'm
really excited because it's something I
have never done before I'm gonna go in
grab my husband and we're gonna be on
our way and then take you all there too
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we look really far away from Toronto and
usually our rides span anywhere from an
hour to two and a half hours or three
hours into the city so the husband and I
like to trade interesting information
and today he has something interesting
to tell you so I did some pretty intense
research on Wikipedia and I checked out
the history of Innisfil and it comes
from the Irish term for the mythical
name for Ireland which was in his failed
so yeah and that's probably Gaelic too
the reason why the husband did the
research on in a scope as we live in
Ennis phones so to my Irish friends out
there is that true does innisfail
translate to Ireland
[Music]
choice divider
hey everyone so I'm finally here at the
Toronto library the Melbourne division
this workshop is extra special for me
because I am from Melbourne and to be
back here feels great it kind of reminds
me of when I was a teenager walking up
and down these streets and before
there's some music pumping that's what I
remember about Melbourne before I go to
any workshops or any kind of encounter
with people I always think about the
intention that I want to set what is the
intention that I want when people are
leaving and the intention today is for
them to feel something that sparks
inside them inspire them to go take
action and go out there and live an
extraordinary life so I'm really excited
a little bit nervous but mostly excited
and we'll go inside and I'll catch you
guys soon
[Music]
so I just had the workshop it was great
I couldn't record much of the people
inside it's just a part of library laws
but it was good it was really good it
was different it wasn't the big group
that I'm used to but it became like a
one-on-one coaching which is what I love
and I think a lot of people are gonna
take action and hold themselves
accountable and do something great a lot
of great words came out of it too which
I'm really excited about anyway we're
gonna go and spend some time with the
family I just got back from doing the
workshop at the library when I was there
I had so many great memories coming back
to me I remember when I was a 16 year
old girl who had nothing just big dreams
and a strong work ethic and how a lot of
people took a chance on me I had these
great teachers the great guidance
counselor's who helped me form a path
for myself to be able to go out there
and achieve my dreams and how they
believed in me believed that I was
capable of doing a lot more than I was
doing at that time and when I was there
I realized that I could be that for
someone now number one I'm not that girl
anymore I have a lot to give and number
two I could do that for someone I can be
the guide for someone I could help them
pave their path I grew up in a really
poor neighborhood where a lot of people
don't get out I was able to get out I
could go back there and do that for
someone else and then hopefully they
could do that for someone else and it
all just kind of comes full circle and
that further solidifies my why my why is
to inspire people to be extraordinary so
they could inspire others too
the same and then how we can all do this
together as one that's the reason why I
make these videos that's a reason why I
want to go to speak that's a reason why
I coach people everything I do is
because of that and being there really
really confirmed it for me even though I
was uncomfortable with it at first I
didn't know how to say it but I'm glad I
did because it showed me and proved to
me that that really is my why so the
question of the day is what is your why
please write in the comments below and
I'll join in on the discussion so my
last episode when I talked about
overcoming my fear I said that I wanted
to speak in front of a lot of people on
stage so I think the next thing I want
to do is like go on a big stage and
speak in front of a lot of
a lot hundreds of people that's what I
would like to do so surprised I actually
have a TEDx talk coming up in Michigan
so for my next challenge I'm going to be
bringing all of you on the road trip I
am so excited to bring you guys along
for my first TEDx talk I have a special
shout out for choreographic arts
choreographic arts growth Congrats Lilly
for conquering your fear my fear is not
to do what I want to do that thing that
is in my heart because I'm afraid to
conquer it I know sounds crazy but
lately I've been feeling the Scourge and
stuck I don't know should be my next
step what should be my next move
choreographic arts first of all thank
you so much for sharing that with us I
do want you to know that you're not
alone and it's okay to feel discouraged
from time to time but I want you to know
that we're all rooting for you so thank
you so much for watching every time an
episode comes out I get so excited to
read your comments and every time you
share something with me in the comments
I feel like I know you a little bit
better and how we're all in this
together again thank you so much and I
will see you guys very very soon